the next one is coming up from Julia I'm
a weight loss educator / coach I've only
been about 20 pounds overweight so not a
great story numbers wise but the victory
in my life against an emotionally driven
overeating is to Mesa definitely huge is
my story enough for july yeah hey Julia
I think speaking for for me I think
you've got a great story just the way
Evan said that you connect to my heart
straightaway you know I think I think
we're all bombarded honestly through the
media and every celebrity is
photoshopped and we are absolutely
pounded with images of what we should
look like and you have to remember
you're an individual everybody's an
individual and you've got to feel good
about yourself when you wake up in the
morning so your stories just compelling
and it's real and it's authentic and it
just connects to me straightaway so I
think that's a great story in and the
more you tell your story honestly the
more confidence you get and the more you
build your self-esteem and the more you
can go out there with your story and the
more you feel confident the more you'll
go to the next stage of this story and
write the second chapter and the third
chapter and the fourth chapter i agree i
would say i would want to learn a little
bit more about the emotionally driven
over eating so that the story isn't that
you were 20 pounds overweight and God
under 20 as much to me as uh what caused
you to motional e / eat like where did
you have parents who picked on you or
friends who didn't believe in you or did
you have a lot of stress at work or like
what caused this thing for you to always
emotionally overeat because that's what
people will be able to connect with
right like oh yeah I have parents like
that or I have friends like that or my
work places like that too and that's
what I end up doing is overeating and
how have you solved that and cracked
that for yourself or now you're
confident and happy and so the numbers
don't have to be the core part of the
story it's more the background and
emotion that goes into it I grew stephen
i can feel the love and energy and
passion that comes out of it and just
you need to believe that your story
is enough right like you don't need our
permission to say it's good enough like
you need to believe this is enough when
you're on a powerful powerful mission to
go up and help are the people who are
emotionally overeating yeah i think this
that you've touched a raw nerve probably
with Evan and me here as well Juliet so
we're not clinical psychologists or
anything like that but we know that no
person on this planet is perfect yet
when you're an entrepreneur you kind of
think of these perfect people they don't
exist we've all got kind of stuff in our
lives and we've all got burns we carry
and this stuff around particularly with
the exposure of social media whether
you're talking teenagers you're talking
any generation there's this perfect kind
of image that you're presented with and
it's just not real so I think something
to help us all is when you think about
your customers the people you're serving
just say they're like us they've got
their vulnerabilities they've got their
weaknesses they've got their anxieties
they got their worries they got you know
and if one of them could be body image
so i think we have got so many kind of
manufacturers elements out there and one
of them is this kind of pursuit of
perfection and it doesn't exist
especially relative to kind of wait so I
you've walked this journey you've
experienced it personally and you you're
able to tell your story today I think
it's a very compelling story